le jour se lève à peine sur les rues de
trappe et ils sont 13 à avoir la tête
tourné vers les sommets le Secours
populaire organise son premier voyage
intergénérationnel à valorsine en Haute
Savoie au programme initiation de ski
balade en raquette et une visite du
glacier du Montblanc la Mer de Glace
grâce au Père Noël vert du Secours
populaire toute la famille croisée peut
partir en vacances content parce que ça
fait de mois qu'on sait donc comme on
leur a dit dès le début ce qu'on aurait
pas dû faire B ça fait de mois qu'il
nous fatigue avec ça donc sont super
pressés quoi voilà il B ils vont
découvrir c'est vrai que bon la neige un
peu attrape mais bon ça rien à voir avec
un séjour au ski je pense qu'ils vont
être sages en plus mais ils vont
profiter ouis ils vont bien s'amuser
vont se défouler si certains sont déjà
équipés pour la neige la plupart n'ont
jamais skillé de quoi oublier un peu le
quotidien et découvrir d'autres horizons
c'est la première fois que tu V SK
oui j'ai déjà touché de la neige
qu'est-ce que tu vas y faire là-bas de
la le du ski faire partir un petit peu
puisils nont pas l'occasion de par
en vacances de pouvoir partager un
moment de convivialité avec d'autres
familles faire de nouvelles rencontres
un moment d'échange de
partage chargement des bagages une
première photo souvenir avant le départ
pour valorine retour prévu le 5
janvier